joining us this morning folks so today
Rob and I were gonna talk about how do
you manage configuration policies and
resources at scale
my name is Sandeep Eric I'm a anthos
advocate for Google cloud and I'm a Rob
Lydell I'm a software engineer for
Google cloud all right so let's start
with configuration so when we if you
take a step back and you sort of look at
the high-level view of the anthos stack
right you start at the bottom we start
with kubernetes and then you layer in
service mesh on top of that and then
we've got a layer for policy controls
which we'll get to shortly and then
you've got your applications and
services and then on the left side of
the diagram we we sort of talk about how
you get configuration or applications
how you get software into that
environment okay those two things and
this is the typical sort of approach
where we're trying to guide customers
around as they think about how to set up
deploy and operate in an Tosun
environment so to start we're gonna
focus on config management how do you
get the objects and resources configured
in your deployment
now how you deliver that configuration
so typically what we still see on a
pretty regular basis is that a lot of
teams are still using coop CTL to apply
changes to their environments right
they're still be doing very imperative
operations and this is really
challenging because as these clusters
grow right not only a number but in
scale in size we see a lot of
large-scale multi-tenant deployments it
can become challenging for operator
teams to sort of continue to use coop
CTL or imperative approaches because COO
Bernays itself as a declarative system
right you declare what you want the
state of the cluster to be and you push
that configuration but that doesn't
really match up to imperative operations
so how do you transition that sort of
imperative approach to one that fits the
kubernetes model better that's more
declarative in nature and the first step
is we take out that imperative approach
and we replace it with a sort of central
repository right where you store that
configuration information so we start
with git okay git repo which is
something you know almost every
technical practitioner is familiar with
let's start with git and inside of that
git repo
we store all of the configuration about
your cluster okay how you configured
your namespaces any additional metadata
labels annotations pods services secrets
volumes you name it if it's a kubernetes
object it can fit in that config remote
and what we're doing with that is we're
trying to trying to create this this
sort of approach where the state of the
cluster is what exactly matches the
state of your repository so if it's not
in the git repo it's not reflected in
your cluster as well once you adopt that
approach right that state that you that
you're trying to declare become that
configuration it you know it's
effectively data and we store it just
like we start code and because we're
using something that's like it it
becomes a process that you can use sort
of typical software development
workflows to kind of manage your
configuration manager environments so
the process of deploying a new config in
production follows the same software
development process they are already
familiar with right if a team needs to
create a new a new configuration they
can branch the repository they can make
their changes they can validate them
locally and then they can have them
merged back in and then those changes
get pushed out to production and as I
mentioned at any given time we want to
make sure the state of your deployments
matches exactly what's specified in that
git repo and so that's where anthos
config management comes in so with a cm
what we're trying to give you is the
ability to define the state of your
deployment and store that in a central
secure git repository the benefits of
doing that are the same benefits that
apply to typical software development
right we have the ability to audit
changes a lot more cleanly now instead
of digging through kubernetes logs and
events and trying to figure out who made
a change and what changed they
introduced that might have broken your
infrastructure we can just trace that
back to a side of git commits and who
authored the commit and maybe even who
merged it in you can revert your
deployment and roll things back a lot
easier right just by making a change in
your git config right you may revert a
commit and now production can can pick
up that that revert that you needed to
do ACM also
self-healing so it watches the cluster
for drift from the configuration so if
by chance someone goes and applies an
imperative operation and changes a
namespace configuration outside of the
normal workflow the mechanism built into
ACM will actually sink that change back
and put it back to the state that's
again reflected in the repository so at
any given time again the state of your
cluster and the state of your deployment
matches exactly what's in source control
and ultimately the best part is that you
can version your deployments just like
you version software so you can tag them
mark them as release candidates etc just
like you would any of your applications
so it's a pretty powerful sort of a
thought process to work through now the
way Anthes config management or ACM
works in our environment from an
architectural perspective and you can
see sort of the middle of the diagram
there's the interconnects right that's
bridging your on-prem environment and
your cloud environment and this would be
true for for a multi cloud scenario as
well but what's happening here is that
you've got the interconnects bridging
the networking between the two and then
in each kubernetes environment or hgk
environment there's a config management
controller that we deploy as an operator
and that controller is what's keeping
things in sync with the repo and the
best part is that repo does not have to
live on cloud that can live in your
on-prem infrastructure so if you want to
make sure if there are you know
particular security or compliance or
guidelines around where your
configuration lives right where the
definition of that lives you can always
keep that on Prem and then have the
config just sort of spread out across
across all of your gku clusters alright
so that's a little bit about how we
manage configuration at scale right and
and let me go back for a quick second
here so the way you kind of configure a
cm is you effectively when you deploy
the the software inside of your
cooperate environment all you really
have to tell it is where does that get
repo live right what is the branch or
the tag you want to use for your
releases and any sort of authentication
information needs to to access that git
repo and once you've done that it's up
and running and now your
stirrers are sort of under that managed
state that ACM provides so that's the
config management piece now how do we
use config management to implement
policy controls
so the sort of act of creating policies
and enforcing them is something we often
call policy management policy you know
think of policies and policy management
is effectively saying I have a set of
rules right a set of governance I want
to apply to all of my environments to
all of my deployment and I want to
enforce those rules in certain ways
either I want to not allow objects that
break those rules or I want to allow
objects that might violate those rules
but I want to be able to audit them and
audit any of those violations on an
ongoing basis now policy management and
config management there's a little bit
of overlap and I think from a mental
model perspective there's sometimes a
little bit of kind of you know
collapsing these two together but they
are very distinct especially in the way
that that ACM sees them so from a config
management perspective the configurating
config management's really all about how
do you store control and govern right
your deployment configuration there's
typically a process for how it gets done
in the case of ACM that's like a get-ups
style process and there's typically a
process for who can do it using
something like kubernetes role based
access control or our back to control
that but ultimately config management's
really about how you know you enforce
object or resource state in their
cluster on the other hand policy
management is about rules right it's
about setting guardrails and applying
governance and it's really more about
can you make a change to a given object
right is that change allowed and how do
we want to enforce those changes right
do we want to again deny them entirely
or will allow those changes to happen
and then audit them for kind of ongoing
violations a lot of times I think the
policy management angle can actually
sound quite a bit like kubernetes are
back in many ways but again if you think
about it our back is about who can make
a change and who has the power to make a
change whereas the policy aspect is
really about is that change even allowed
so it's a little bit of a higher level
view of the
problem now I mentioned guardrails and
governments you know kübra Hayes is an
incredibly powerful distributed system
right and powerful systems like that
typically needs some kind of control
because you want to watch out for
potential problem spots right you want
to make sure you haven't given a
particular set of users too many
privileges right you don't to give them
too much power to make changes you want
to make sure that services are locked
down and that they can only be accessed
by other services you you deem
appropriate or by a certain parties you
deem appropriate and obviously you want
to watch out for things like
exfiltration you don't want data leaving
your environments in an unintended
fashion but on the other hand those
controls that you want to use that
governance needs to be agile and
flexible right you want to be able to
scope that governance and that control
very narrowly to only the objects you
really care about and you want those
policies and those controls to be
written by the people who know the
compliance the regulatory work your
organization's policies best so you got
to make it easy to develop and deploy
them because at the end of the day what
we're trying to get you is safe
deployments we don't want anything in
production that could violate any of the
rules we need to worry about on a
regular basis so as part of ACM we have
another component in wrapped in there
called ACM policy controller policy
controller is based on a project from
open policy agent and gatekeeper right
gatekeepers sort of an offshoot of open
policy agent and open policy agent is
really just a general purpose policy
engine right you write a policy you hand
it some data it makes a decision based
on those two things does that data
violate the policy or is it not violate
the policy and what gatekeeper and by
extension ACM policy controller do is it
takes that policy engine and it makes it
a sort of first-class citizen in your
kubernetes environment and it makes it
into an admission controller so now that
means the policy mechanism is sort of
right alongside the ability to admit
objects to the cluster so now you can
apply rules upon
and so something that could potentially
violate the rules that your organization
has won't get admitted to the cluster or
again you could say things like well I
want to allow this to happen but I want
to audit anyone who's you know
potentially out of compliance it has
that sort of capability but because it
integrates again as a first-class
citizen with kubernetes and with gke by
extension all of the standard kubernetes
tooling you're used to is it fits right
alongside with it it can be used
alongside with it so let's talk about a
policy in depth and what the structure
looks like so there's two parts to a
policy right there is the sort of rule
definition which is written in a
language called rego which is part of
the OPA package the open policy agent
package and then there's the actual
packaging of that rule and giving it to
kubernetes and so that packaging is
called a constraint template and it's a
parameterised piece right you can apply
arguments you can scope it down but
ultimately the the policy approach is
written is is built into two components
one is the rule definition and the
second part is how that rule gets
enforced so the constraint template here
that you see is the rule definition what
are we trying to enforce what are we
trying to evaluate how many of you are
familiar with SEO in the room all right
a handful so you'll hear more about SEO
later today but one of the one of the
you know most powerful aspects of this
do is that you can automatically enable
things like M TLS right so mutually
authenticate services and clients in
your cluster but one of your
organization's policies could be hey we
want to make sure that every service
that gets deployed every client in our
environment must support mutual TLS and
you want to also make sure that no one
turns that off right you don't want
anyone to bypass that because that could
be possible someone who has the
appropriate auerbach permissions could
say well my service is special I want to
turn off M TLS because we don't want to
support it today so what this rule is
actually doing is it's evaluating part
of that process and saying hey if you
try to turn off MPLS I'm going to catch
that and that's gonna throw a violation
so this is the rule that catches that
and then the enforcement half is
packaged in something called a
constraint and let me jump back a quick
second but
what we're doing in this policy in this
constraint template is if you look at
that kind field about 1/3 of the way
down
we're actually defining a new custom
resource for kubernetes so we're saying
hey there is now a new resource called
destination rule TLS enabled that lives
in the kubernetes environment and if you
actually run coop CTL get c RDS you'll
see that in the list so what the
constraint does is it actually takes
that CR and it creates another another
spec based around that and it lets us
scope the enforcement and so there's two
parts that's that are really important
one is enforcement action about a third
of the way down right in this example
I've set this constraint to be deny so
if anybody tries to submit a destination
rule that deactivates em TLS that thing
will get denied admission for the
cluster entirely it won't even get in
and the second part of it is about
halfway down where I'm actually scoping
that to a particular particular API
object and to a particular namespace so
I'm saying only scope this rule to
destination rule objects that are part
of the sto API and only look for them in
the default namespace now the nice thing
is with with ACM policy controller you
can actually adjust that scoping a
little bit you can say I want to have it
apply to any namespace that has the
following labels or that doesn't have
the following labels so you can actually
control the enforcement and application
of that constraint as well and so now
what would happen if we were to push
that constraint template and that
corresponding constraint is if I try to
push this new destination rule that
disables M TLS GK will accept the object
the admission controller will then
review it and then decide and see that
it violates the rule we've laid out and
then just kick it right back and say
sorry we can't take it right and you can
supply your own custom error messages
and things like that but it'll
automatically just push that object back
out and say I can't accept this
in because again it violates a rule so
now there are three sort of stages to
the policy development process all right
if there's obviously the authoring step
which is where you're gonna start are
going to validate the rules in your
approach and then there's the
application of it where you may want to
just firmly deny anything that is out of
compliance or that violates your rules
or there's a third step where you can
say we want to allow objects in that may
potentially have violations and we just
want to audit them right and there are
things where you may want to audit
contribu maybe while audit controls for
maybe labels or annotations but for
something that's violating again
regulatory compliance or any kind of
corporate IT policy those maybe you know
objects where you want to deny admission
entirely right again we want to watch
out for things like data exfiltration or
overexposed services so some of the
example policy use cases and and by the
way I should mention there's actually a
whole bunch that are already included
with ACM policy controller things like
checking for required labels or
particular annotations or a particular
structure you can do things with
policies like make sure that resource
constraints are baked in right you could
say hey no pods and services can be
deployed in this cluster unless they
actually call out how much CPU and RAM
they need all right so that we can make
sure that we're not you know overdoing
the amount of resources we're gonna
consume for a given pot or service but
particularly around sort of security
control you know security concerns we
can watch out for things like only
allowing access from certain domains
within your organization right so a
service within a particular domain can
access another one but one outside of
that list of domains may not be able to
access services okay hey look in the
example I showed earlier you know we can
require strict m TLS across the board
and make sure that stays enforced so
that no one can turn off that
authentication piece you may want to
implement controls like service a kentuc
to service B but service a definitely
cannot talk to service C and make that a
policy so again if anyone tries to
bypass that or override it they will
actually get booted that configuration
won't be allowed into their cluster and
there are many other examples these are
just a few and we're happy to kind of
answer questions around them as we have
time to afterwards so with that I'm
going to hand it off to Rob to talk
about managing and platform resources
yeah so thanks Andy
kind of bringing this together how could
you apply the same techniques Andy
talked about to your cloud
infrastructure that's not possible today
you're gonna have some sort of split
brain approach you're gonna have Cooper
Denny's applications managed through
your kubernetes tool chain and then you
have your cloud resources managed
through some other mechanism cloud or
manager etc we have now made available a
new product GCP config connector and
this allows you to manage your cloud
infrastructure in a kubernetes native
way and since it is kubernetes native
integrations like Anthes config
management just work with it the idea
here is that you cuddle config
management or API clients I guess queue
petals and API client but API clients
like your CI ZD pipeline and they can
push configuration to the kubernetes api
server and then GCP config connector
will take that declared configuration
their intended state and it'll make it a
reality in GCP so a config connector
like I said is cubed a is native the
actual configuration is care a care M
you come to expect from kubernetes you
can use the k api's or q pedal to
manipulate it it allows you to declare
your intended state with the third of
configuration so you avoid a lot of the
issues that come from imperative
workflows it is eventually consistent so
you can apply your configuration in any
order you want and it will eventually
reach the intestate you intend that also
means it'll be quicker and more
performant it's idempotent you can apply
the same configuration over and over
again and you'll see no change and a
combat stripped you can ensure that
changes made by operators outside of the
your applications CI CD push flow I'll
revert it back so you don't end up in
state where there are changes that are
not in your repository it's available
through anthos as a Jiki add-on or
manual installation and it's in beta now
and going GA in q1 so here's a little
talk about the actual krm on the right
we have two examples we have a hub sub
topic which pub/sub is you know it's
popular tcp service a topic is a
resource within pub/sub and then we have
a pub sub subscription a subscription is
associated with a topic that's just the
way subscriptions work and in this
example you can see in the subscriptions
spec we have a field called topic ref
and in topic ref we say the name is my
topic and that's saying this
subscription is associated with that
topic and that's just an example of how
this is written how these configurations
work in the way you would expect a
kubernetes resource to work and in terms
of what resources are supported we
support resources from all the services
listed there notably compute spanner
storage and resource coverage is
expanding so putting it all together you
can use your an throws configuration and
policy management to manage your GCP
infrastructure as well so you can bring
all those techniques of GCP in addition
you can standardize your tool chain on
kubernetes tool chains or accrue bidets
tools which will which will simplify
your environment for developers and make
them more productive so that'll give you
back more of your most limited resource
which is developer time and they'll have
more time to work on your applications
and things them out of your business and
that's it for policy configuration
management Sandeep and I and other
Googlers are available to answer any
questions as needed thank you
[Applause]